president biden now claiming he's gotten
control of the border crisis
but he's also blasting the previous
administration for the conditions
that led to a surge of migrants
mr president 170 000 people
migrants apprehended at the border it's
a 20-year record
they're 22 000 unaccompanied children in
our country
right now that's that's a record that
sounds to most folks like a crisis
well look it's way down now we've now
gotten control
for example we have they didn't plan for
which it comes every year this
flow whether it's 22 000 they didn't
have the beds that were available
they didn't plan for the overflow
the president's comments come as we
learn of a sickening story
of possible human smuggling police now
investigating a case in houston texas
where more than 90 people were
discovered packed
inside a home the assistant police chief
giving us more details
we had our tactical operations team swat
go in and execute the search warrant and
when they got inside the house they
realized that this is
actually going to turn into a smuggling
human smuggling investigation we
realized that there were over 90
people inside are concerned that there
may be
some positive coveted cases inside the
house
katie uh you know this is just so
upsetting but
human smuggling in houston as tragic as
it might be
it's nothing new i think i saw today's
2019 in texas more than a thousand
people freed
from human smugglers i'm wondering
is it possible that immigration reform
might lessen the pressure that people
would want to even put themselves their
children in the hands of smugglers
no actually any kind of amnesty or
you know immigration reform at this
point would only actually
continue this massive flow of people
into the country because they haven't
stopped the flow
and so if you're giving incentives to
come to the country and rewarding people
for breaking the law and coming here
illegally without a mechanism to
stop them at the border from coming or
to turn them away or to tell them not to
come at all in the first place
then you're only creating another crisis
in the future we've been hearing about
the dreamers
for decades now really a decade we've
heard about
daca recipients for years on end well
right now
the biden administration is creating a
whole new generation
of quote daca recipients of dreamers
while they refuse to
stop the flow of people from coming into
the country so they're creating a crisis
down the road
and democrats have already said they're
not interested in any kind of border
security
and today the pentagon said they're not
going to continue building any part of
the border wall
and they're taking back the the funding
that they got for that well pieces of
wall that have already been paid for by
the taxpayer
are sitting in lots and rotting so they
have no
that wouldn't help and i don't think
this administration has any intention
of doing anything to stop the flow into
the country
so jesse the president of course be in
his speech to the congress this week's
asked congress to act uh he said
specifically
let's you know something we can agree on
is the dreamers
do you think congress can do anything
more than just take selfies at the
border
no because joe biden doesn't want to
solve the crisis he's doing what his
donors want
his donors want open borders because
they benefit from the cheap labor
and the cheap labor crushes their
competition which is small business
and i'll explain how juan say you're
remodeling your bathroom
and you can hire an american company mom
and pop contractor been here for
generations
they pay insurance they have their
licenses and they pay their workers a
fair wage and
they pay taxes they'll give you a quote
for about 10 grand
or maybe word of mouth you hear about an
illegal immigrant
he has no insurance no licenses but he's
got a team of really hard-working guys
from central america and they don't pay
any taxes and
he'll probably give you a quote five
grand cash
now what are you gonna do you're gonna
pay the guy
five grand cash they'll do the same
exact job
they'll take the money they won't pay
any taxes and they'll wire probably 75
percent of it
back home to their families in guatemala
what does that do to the american
workers juan
it depresses wages it takes away their
jobs
and it sends money overseas and we get
less tax receipts that we can spend on
americans
how does that help the american worker
it doesn't
i agree with you i i mean i think that's
a reason for reform but anyway
you agree greg you agree i'm glad you
agree
i agree i think that's the reason i
think that's an impetus for
for immigration reform to get more
immigrants into the tax system but
anyway
greg today the president was heckled in
atlanta
by people who were calling uh for an end
to ice and end to detention of
immigrants it seems like he's getting
pressure from all sides
i think i can use the new democrat
slogan it's nothing new
that's the new thing you look at illegal
immigration hey it's nothing new
hey look there's a house with 90 people
trapped inside and 2 000 square feet
what new york city
people call spacious uh but hey that's
nothing new
hey there's a spike in crime nothing new
if you aren't gonna get mad about the
forced labor the abuse of children the
trafficking
how about this take a page out of
biden's book it's the lack of masks and
the lack of social distancing in that
house
of 90 people that you should be truly
outraged about
tucker uh unembarrassed question for you
are you
are you uh how do you think what do you
think about biden saying hey you know
what the shelf was beer when i got here
not enough staff not enough people what
do you say to that i mean
look this is this if you're looking for
an attack on our democracy this is it
they don't
care about the conditions of the people
at the border the children in cages they
don't care about human trafficking most
immigration at this point is human
trafficking
that's what it is they only care about
stacking the electorate by the way
immigration reform the reagan amnesty of
86 led to a republican amnesty
led to a massive flood of illegal
immigration so that that's what they
want
they want to change who votes so they
win
they're diluting the votes of americans
of all backgrounds
and that is an attack on democracy
period this is it we're watching it
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else